-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
We hope you're doing well,
and now, let's get to the news.
It was announced yesterday
that President Biden
will follow the FDA
recommendation that those
65 and older receive a
coronavirus vaccine booster.
Well, he is used to needing
three shots.
During his address to the U.N.
General assembly today,
President Biden announced
that the U.S.
will make a $10 billion
commitment to end hunger.
Pretty impressive, especially
compared to the previous
president who spent about
300 bucks.
Brazilian President
Jair Bolsonaro this morning
entered the U.N. General
Assembly hall unvaccinated,
violating both U.N. rules
and New York law.
But he got a hero's welcome
on Staten Island.
Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau won yesterday's
snap election, and in keeping
with Canadian tradition,
he gave a long, heartfelt
victory apology.
President Biden yesterday
recognized the tenth anniversary
of the end of the "Don't ask,
Don't tell" military policy.
Now, "Don't ask, Don't tell"
refers to Afghanistan.
Former President Trump sent
a letter last week
to Georgia's Secretary of State
Brad Raffensperger
asking him to consider
decertifying the 2020 election.
Dude, just give up.
You know you don't have to be
President to play golf, right?
According to a new survey,
9 percent of Americans said
that they drink less than one
cup of water a day.
At least, I think that's
what they said.
Their voices were very raspy.
Today was national New York day.
Ah, yes, finally,
a day for New Yorkers
to think they're special.
"Oh, you're from New York.
Uh-huh.
And you say the pizza
is good there?
Huh."
Authorities in New York
are searching for a man
who allegedly rolled a bike
onto the subway tracks
over the weekend,
which caused an explosion
when it was hit by a train.
Officials condemn
this behavior and said,
"When you're done
with the Citi bike,
you're supposed to chuck it
in the Hudson."